Transcriptor: Analía Moyano
Revisor: Penny Martínez
Vamos a hablar diez minutos
sobre cómo hacer un doctorado.
Pero para hablar sobre
cómo hacer un doctorado,
primero tenemos que entender
qué es un doctorado.
Es algo de lo que se habla mucho, pero
¿sabemos qué es hacer una tesis doctoral?
Todos sabemos que cuando uno
acaba su formación básica,
acaba el bachillerato, el instituto,
y puede continuar sus estudios
haciendo un grado,
lo que antes se llamaba
"hacer una carrera",
que típicamente dura tres,
cuatro o cinco años.
Muchas personas,
acabado este periodo formativo,
se incorporan al mundo laboral
y otros deciden continuar un poco más,
uno o dos años, haciendo
lo que se llama, un máster oficial.
La mayoría, en ese momento,
acaba su periplo universitario
y empieza a trabajar.
Y unos pocos, muy pocos,
continúan sus estudios
hacia lo que se conoce
como estudios de tercer ciclo,
que es hacer un doctorado,
una tesis doctoral.
Y hay una diferencia esencial
entre lo que es hacer un doctorado
y todos los estudios anteriores,
lo que es hacer un grado o un máster.
Cuando uno hace un grado o un máster
está centrado en adquirir conocimientos,
en formarse, con la esperanza,
muchas veces vana,
de encontrar un buen
puesto de trabajo al terminar.
Sin embargo, cuando uno hace una tesis,
el objetivo no es adquirir conocimientos;
muy al contrario,
cuando uno hace una tesis,
el objetivo es generar conocimientos.
Uno no adquiere su título de doctor
hasta que no hace una aportación original
en el área de conocimiento
en el que está haciendo la tesis.
Tiene que contribuir
al acervo científico, en su campo,
o de lo contrario nunca será doctor.
Por tanto, vemos que es un enfoque
radicalmente distinto
a los estudios de primer
y segundo grado universitario.
Si uno investiga un poco qué es
esto de hacer una tesis doctoral,
y si es fácil o difícil,
se encuentra con cosas como esta:
esta es una revista
académica, "Research Policy",
el artículo es relativamente
reciente, de 2017,
y abre con un resumen
bastante alentador:
"Uno de cada dos estudiantes de doctorado
experimentan desórdenes psicológicos
y uno de cada tres está en riesgo
de padecer un trastorno psiquiátrico".
(Risas)
Esta es una revista académica, insisto,
basada en un estudio científico serio.
Y vamos a ver qué dicen
en medios más generalistas.
Nos vamos a "The Economist".
En "The Economist" un artículo dice:
"Por qué hacer un doctorado
es casi siempre una pérdida de tiempo".
También tremendamente estimulante.
Pero si uno continúa
y busca en Youtube,
cosa que yo he hecho,
pues ve vídeos de gente que habla
de su experiencia haciendo el doctorado,
y básicamente, la conclusión
que se saca tras ver 3 o 4 vídeos
es que uno no va a la universidad
a hacer un doctorado,
en realidad, a donde va es al infierno
a ser sometido a torturas inmisericordes
durante un periodo de tiempo
no inferior a tres años.
Esa es la conclusión que uno saca.
Y yo quiero dar una visión
completamente distinta.
Mi visión es que hacer un doctorado
es algo terriblemente exigente,
terriblemente difícil, pero sobre todo,
tremendamente divertido.
Y no hablo por hablar;
a mí me parece tan divertido,
que yo ya he hecho tres.
(Risas)
Ese, de hecho, es mi gorro
para los actos académicos,
tres doctorados, tres colores.
(Risas)
Así que, efectivamente, es una
actividad tremendamente divertida;
pero para que sea divertida
me gustaría dar cuatro consejos.
Y solo cuatro,
que son los cuatro consejos
que yo he seguido
y, desde luego a mí
me han funcionado muy bien.
El primero de ellos es hacer
un ejercicio introspectivo
de cuál es mi motivación
para hacer la tesis doctoral.
Esto es fundamental, tengo que
pensar si soy una persona
para la que tiene sentido hacer una tesis.
Pensar si soy un especialista o un atón.
Atón es una palabra que he sacado
de un libro de Philip José Farmer:
"Los amantes", una novela
que me gusta mucho,
y es el acrónimo de:
"Aprendiz de todo, oficial de nada"
un generalista.
(Risas)
Si uno es un atón,
el doctorado no es para él.
Porque hacer una tesis doctoral
consiste en ser un superespecialista
en un área muy concreta, uno se va a
pasar cuatro o cinco años de su vida
estudiando una cosa súper pequeña,
súper concreta y en muchísima profundidad.
Por tanto esa es la primera reflexión:
plantearnos si el doctorado es algo
que encaja con nuestro perfil.
La segunda reflexión es para qué
queremos hacer un doctorado,
cuál es nuestra motivación extrínseca,
qué objetivo pretendemos.
Si uno se quiere dedicar a la universidad
tiene que hacer una tesis,
porque para ser profesor universitario
a tiempo completo hace falta ser doctor,
que es condición,
necesaria pero no suficiente
porque ahora, además,
hay que estar acreditado
y otra serie de cosas.
Pero, como mínimo,
uno tiene que ser doctor.
Si uno se va a dedicar
al ámbito empresarial,
lamento decirle que hay formas
bastante más eficientes
de emplear su tiempo y su esfuerzo.
Ahora profundizaré en ese particular.
Y la tercera pregunta que uno debe hacerse
es si se ve con fuerzas para tener
suficiente motivación intrínseca.
Motivación intrínseca es:
si se ve capaz de disfrutar
durante el proceso de hacer la tesis
por el mero hecho de hacerla,
disfrutar con el proceso.
Como decía un profesor mío
hace muchos años:
"En España, hacer un doctorado solo
sirve para que te atropelle un camión".
(Risas)
¿A qué se estaba refiriendo con esto?
Se estaba refiriendo a que,
en otros países no sucede,
pero en España así es, hacer un
doctorado en el ámbito empresarial
no se valora demasiado.
Y vuelvo a lo que decía antes,
si uno se quiere dedicar
al mundo corporativo,
hay formas más eficientes
de emplear su tiempo.
El segundo consejo es qué tema elijo.
Puede parecer una perogrullada,
pero tiene que ser un tema
que nos interese a nosotros,
que nos apasione,
porque si uno se va a pasar
de tres a cinco años
focalizado en un único tema
que sea un tema que
nos apasione de verdad.
¿Y esto qué implica?
Que no debemos dejarnos seducir
por presiones externas,
una tentación muy grande.
Uno acaba su grado en la universidad,
continúa con su máster
y finalizado ese periodo
quiere continuar haciendo una tesis
y dice: "Ya llevo muchos años
en esta universidad, me quedo aquí,
voy a ver qué líneas
de investigación ofrece
y me adhiero a una de ellas".
Gravísimo error.
El procedimiento
debe ser justo el contrario:
plantearme qué es lo que a mí me interesa,
cuáles son las líneas de investigación
en las que quiero trabajar
y buscar dónde me pueden ofrecer
esas líneas de investigación.
Y si eso implica moverme
de universidad, me muevo;
y si eso implica irme
a otra parte, pues me voy,
pero no dejarse influir
por las opiniones de otros.
Yo os voy a contar una
anécdota real que me pasó,
no fue en mi primer doctorado
fue, de hecho, más adelante,
pero yo estaba buscando un
director de tesis que me llevase
sobre un tema en concreto
que me interesaba,
entonces me entrevisté con varios
posibles directores de tesis,
y en una reunión con uno de ellos
después de que le explicara
lo que quería hacer,
me dijo: "Tú lo que tienes
que hacer es matricularte,
y cuando ya estés admitido en el programa,
ya te diré en qué tienes que investigar".
Evidentemente,
salí corriendo sin mirar atrás.
Eso no debe ser así.
El tema de tesis tiene
que gustarnos a nosotros.
No tiene que gustarle al director de tesis
Y si no hay coincidencia, pues nos
buscamos otro director de tesis.
Tercer punto,
y desde mi punto de vista,
el más clave de todos:
elegir un buen director de tesis.
Esto es absolutamente fundamental.
Vuelvo a lo de antes.
Uno va a pasar entre tres y cinco años
dedicado a un tema súper concreto
y dedicándole muchísimo trabajo
y muchísimo esfuerzo.
Gastemos unas pocas semanas
en buscar un buen director.
Un buen director no es el que sabe más;
sino el que nos encaja a nosotros
según lo que queremos hacer,
cómo somos personalmente,
y un montón de factores más.
Gastemos un poco de tiempo
en buscar un director que nos encaje.
Y esto pasa por una persona
que domina el tema,
con el que tengamos feeling,
y esto es fundamental.
No sólo debe dominar el tema,
también tenemos que estar
confortables trabajando con él,
y que te vaya a dedicar tiempo.
Que no sea una persona
demasiado ocupada
que no pueda dedicarte tiempo.
Y una vez que elegí director de tesis,
y estoy seguro que esa es la
persona que tiene que llevar
mi proyecto de investigación,
hacerle caso.
Hay que hacerle caso aunque a veces
nos diga cosas que parecen raras.
¿Por qué?
Porque va a pasar.
Nos va a decir cosas que no nos gustan
y con las que no concordaremos.
Os cuento un anécdota real.
Fue en mi primer doctorado.
Yo llevaba un tema de tesis muy concreto
que me interesaba en especial
y además había preparado
un proyecto de investigación,
entonces fui a ver a mi director de tesis,
y le dije: "Mira, este es el tema de tesis
que quiero trabajar
y además te traigo
mi proyecto de investigación".
Lo que él me dijo
con absoluta franqueza fue:
"Oye, el tema, muy bien,
si el tema te interesa
nos centramos aquí,
pero no es un proyecto de investigación,
es un proyecto de consultoría,
y jamás va a ser una tesis doctoral".
¿Lo entendí en aquel momento?
En absoluto.
Y no estaba de acuerdo.
Pero por suerte le hice caso.
Y nunca le estaré lo suficientemente
agradecido por esa sinceridad.
Porque si no hubiera sido tan
sincero y no me hubiera dicho eso,
que entonces no entendí,
y si yo no le hubiera hecho caso,
hoy no sería doctor.
Porque visto en perspectiva,
tenía toda la razón.
Ese no era un proyecto
para ser una tesis doctoral.
Eso era otra cosa.
Pero en ese momento no lo entendí.
Por tanto, cada vez que encontremos
un conflicto con nuestro
director de tesis,
que va a pasar,
mi consejo es: hacedle caso.
Probablemente él tiene razón,
y vosotros no.
Esa es la conclusión a la que he llegado.
Simplemente por una
cuestión de experiencia.
Y el cuarto consejo
que también me gustaría dar
a aquellos que quieran hacer una tesis,
es la actitud.
Leí una frase hace mucho tiempo;
no sé de quién es, pero decía:
"Más importante que las cosas que te pasan
es cómo te las cuentas".
Me parece una frase brillante
para casi todas las facetas de la vida
y especialmente interesante para
este tema que nos ocupa hoy.
¿Por qué?
Porque nos gustaría que
una tesis fuera algo como esto:
uno empieza en el punto azul y
se va acercando linealmente a su objetivo
que es defender la tesis,
punto rojo.
Esto es lo que nos gustaría.
La realidad de hacer una tesis
se parece más a esto:
vamos girando en círculos,
alrededor de nuestro objetivo final,
acercándonos cada vez más,
pero no siguiendo un camino lineal.
Esa es la realidad.
Y tenemos que asumirla.
Muchas veces nos vamos a sentir así:
metidos en un especie de atractor extraño,
me refiero al término matemático
de atractor extraño,
en el que vamos oscilando
en torno a nuestro objetivo,
pero que no es que no
nos estemos acercando,
sino que parece que estamos
más lejos que cuando empezamos.
Esta sensación la hemos tenido
los que hemos hecho un doctorado,
y la tendrán los que
lo hagan a partir de ahora.
Es absolutamente inevitable que pase.
Y cuando esto nos pase,
tenemos que acordarnos de esto:
"Más importante que las cosas que te pasan
es cómo te las cuentas".
Tenemos que autoconvencernos
de que estamos disfrutando del proceso.
Porque nuestra motivación
para hacer la tesis será la que sea,
pero lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es convencernos
de que estamos disfrutando del proceso,
de que el mero hecho de hacer la tesis
es divertido, es apasionante
y estamos aprendiendo mucho.
El proceso merece la pena.
Centrarnos en el proceso.
No únicamente en el objetivo.
De lo contrario, vamos a sufrir bastante.
En resumen, mis cuatro consejos
para aquellos que quieran hacer
un doctorado, son:
hacer una reflexión,
pensar si el doctorado es o no para mí,
en función de mi perfil.
Y además, plantearme cuál
es el objetivo que tengo.
En segundo lugar, buscar un tema
que realmente me apasione.
Y no digo que me guste;
digo que me apasione.
Y no dejarse influir
por presiones externas.
En tercer lugar, dedicar tiempo
a buscar un director de tesis
que encaje con nuestros objetivos,
y esto es fundamental.
Y en cuarto lugar, actitud.
Motivación intrínseca.
No centrarnos solo en:
"Quiero ser doctor y voy a ser doctor"
por las razones que sean,
sino disfrutar del proceso
de hacer una tesis,
y convencernos de que estamos
disfrutando haciendo la tesis.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)